I have a dream.
The time had just come when I had been pushed...
...as far as I could stand to be pushed, I suppose.
I shook up the world!
My presence here is one additional bit of evidence...
...that the American dream need not forever be deferred.
I think it made all of us realize that we had a voice.
When radical movements emerge, they create their own temporalities.
They create their own sense of help.
Race isn't real.
It's a concept we invented to divide and separate people, you know what I'm saying?
And I realized that greatness of something beyond yourself.
Amidst all this chaos and turbulence,...
...there's an opportunity to create a new vision of the American dream.
We have not ended racial castes in America,...
...we have merely redesigned it.
Fight the power!
Fight!
Others have succeeded before me.
I know I can get through this.
They were gonna show America what they could be...
...and in doing so, show America what it could be.